so nickel is a metal which can produce
allergies in some people people get
allergic to nickel and it's a metal
which was is found in Canada and salute
big Monde founder of the company that
later became icy I discovered a process
for extracting nickel from the from the
all using carbon monoxide and started a
huge Factory in on the south coast in of
Wales and the so called nickel carbonyl
was really quite an important industrial
compound even though it was
fantastically toxic and it's unusual as
a metal compound because it boils at
room temperature and usually when thinks
of metal compounds as being salts nickel
is now used quite a lot in the plating
industry for plating materials big iron
in steel in particular and then often
you will put chromium or something on
top used to be used for plating the
insides of tins for peas and things like
that and sometimes the sulfur of the
front inside the peas would be released
by bacteria and would react to form
strange black spots all over the inside
of the tin